la victoire de l'équipe de france à la
toute dernière minute aux tirs au but un
match d'une qualité exceptionnelle pour
les tricolores qui ont démontré qu'ils
étaient capables d'aller en demi finale
les départs pour les vacances d'été
jours en orange sur les routes d'avant
un samedi classé rouge dans les gares
350 mille voyageurs attendus aujourd'hui
à trafic aérien plus dense de violents
incendies touchent la floride aux états
unis des dizaines de milliers
d'habitants sont évacués les flammes
hors de contrôle le sont à moins d'une
centaine de kilomètres du parc
d'attraction disney madame monsieur
bonsoir un suspense diabolique une
équipe de france qui a mené pendant les
deux premières mi-temps de bout en bout
ce match pour la demi finale
et l'impensable les tirs au but qui
finalement récompensée de savoir faire
et le talent des tricolores
c'est le coeur de tout un pays qui a
battu à l'unisson pendant ces dernières
minutes du match
la liesse la joie des supporteurs est à
la mesure de l'événement
nous retrouvons en direct des champs
elysées françois brabant ambiance de
fête et la foule qui grossit j'imagine
de minute en minute
mais vous l'entendez très certainement
derrière moi béatrice c'est le concert
de klaxons c'est le délire sur les
champs elysées ici sur la plus belle
avenue du monde où les supporters les
plus heureux du monde n'ont pas tardé à
descendre peut-être que trois minutes
seulement après le
altit manqué par les joueurs italiens et
belges étaient tous là ils sont descendu
à pied en voiture ils sont venus avec
les drapeaux bleu blanc rouge ils sont
venus avec les visages aux couleurs de
l'équipe d'aimé jacquet ils sont venus
laissé éclater leur joie pour ce qui
devrait être une soirée très très
longues sur les champs elysées y'avait
même sur les terrasses des cafés
quelques serveurs sympa qui servait les
coupes de champagne comme ça pour un
petit peu tout le monde histoire de
fêter la victoire des bleus la victoire
voilà on a gagné la victoire des bleus
sera fêté jusqu'au bout de la nuit
même si on a prévu un dispositif
évidemment de sécurité pour éviter que
l'on tousse viable soit un petit peu
trop débordant emmenés par zinédine
zidane l'équipe de france a montré
qu'elle était prête comme elle le disait
pour aller en demi finale peut-être même
en finale c'est une équipe battante
attaquante inventive qui s'est mesuré à
la squadra azurra le match le plus
important de toute une carrière peut
être même de leur vie
résumé de ce match unique qui sait jouer
vous le savez aux tirs au but à la toute
dernière seconde laurent frédéric bollée
19h13 50 secondes si luigi di biagio
rate son penalty la france est qualifiée
pour les demi finales de la coupe du
monde
une balle sur la barre et c'est la
délivrance la france vient d'éliminer
d'italie 4 tirs au but à 3 le stade de
france chavire
la belle aventure va pouvoir continuer
pour les joueurs d'aimé jacquet avant
même le début du match
un présage de bonnes heures peut-être
blanc et barthez les français sont bien
décidés à jouer crânement leur chance et
ça commence par un festival d'actions et
occasion c'est zidane de retour après sa
suspension qui allume la première mèche
dès la 4e minute
c'est ensuite emmanuel petit il ajoute
fines bulles car s'interpose
c'est ensuite stéphane guivarc'h qui
tente le geste parfait bien exécuté mais
arrêtez alors après ce début en fanfare
les italiens se révèle la tête de vieri
donne des sueurs froides
le tir du même vieri peu après inquiète
la première mi-temps touche à sa fin et
les bleus pardon et blanc vont avoir
leur meilleure occasion djorkaeff tout
seul ça passe à côté
sur le banc aimé jacquet dit le match de
manière intense
deuxième mi-temps et zidane l'artiste
qui sert thierry henry qui vient de
rentrer avec david trezeguet c'est raté
mais la jeune garde monégasque se fait
remarquer d'emblée changement aussi pour
l'italie
del piero cède sa place à roberto baggio
une vedette sort une star entre ça peut
changer beaucoup de choses comme par
hasard voici les italiens beaucoup plus
dangereux que ce soit de la tête ou du
pied l'italie résiste et c'est
logiquement le match nul 0 0 à la fin du
temps réglementaire prolongation et le
but en or qui se fait désirer
baggio à l'appel de match les français
ont vu le spectre de l'élimination
youri djorkaeff à son tour à la balle de
match les italiens respire ils ont
peut-être que ce boulet les penaltys au
deuxième tir de la terrine aux cessions
des chaînes télé la radio donne
pratiquement la balle a pas dû le cas
mais il doit y avoir un bon génie qui
rôdent albertini rate aussitôt après les
derniers des cinq premiers tireurs rives
laurent blanc rend plus à lui sur la
france doit maintenant parié sur un
échec
ledit biasio
on le sait c'est ce qui arrive la france
pourra bien jouer sa quatrième demi
finale de coupe du monde
mais cette fois dans ça mais je vous
propose tout de suite de rejoindre
vienne la voix qui est aux côtés du
capitaine de l'équipe de france didier
deschamps on vient de vienne nous
rejoindre didier j'imagine que c'est
peut-être une des plus belles victoires
que vous ayez réussi
certains oui c'est ma première coupe du
monde je crois qu arriver en demi-finale
de cette compétition c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
à l'heure actuelle c'est vrai qu'on a eu
un match difficile aujourd'hui mais on
voulait tellement et à tout prix cette
victoire on a été la chercher au fond de
nous on a souffert mais je pense qu'on a
été récompensé les matches qu'on a
réalisé vous pensiez venir à bout plus
rapidement plus facilement de vos
copains italien on aurait dû je pense
qu'on a eu les meilleures occasions n'a
pas été assez réalistes encore ce soir
c'est vrai que ça nous fait défaut un
petit peu déjà contre le paraguay
et ça nous oblige à faire des efforts
vraiment beaucoup plus important parce
que les meilleurs au cassis nous qui les
avons eus se sont contentés de contrôler
et de jouer par à-coups
ils ont pas eu de véritable occasion si
ce n'est dans les prolongations je crois
que par la frappe de vieri lui aussi en
première mi-temps et le lobe de roberto
baggio autrement je crois qu'on a
maîtrisé notre sujet de bout en bout du
match vous savez quand même que dix
minutes après la fin du match j'avais
encore des spectateurs dans les tribunes
appelé à scander vous non a scandé
l'équipe de france ça vous fait quoi
pour ces tiendra bon moyen d'aller au
bout et ça nous fait chaud au coeur je
crois que les français ont pris
conscience qu'on avait une équipe très
compétitive qui a été décrié un peu
avant la compétition malheureusement
mais nous on savait au fond de nous on
est des compétiteurs et on voulait aller
au bout bon il reste encore un dernier
obstacle il sera encore difficile à
franchir mais on sent que il ya une
ferveur une patiente derrière cette
équipe et on fera tout pour que les gens
soient fiers nous
didier on vous retrouve nous dès demain
à clairefontaine pour l'entraînement les
téléspectateurs vous retrouve mercredi
pour la demi finale ce sera encore ici
au stade de france mais à 21h et puis au
stade de france parmi les 80 mille
supporteurs le premier d'entre eux
jacques chirac qui félicite les
tricolores nous l'écoutons
c'est vraiment le bonheur après le
stress cottage nous avons fait un super
boulot et
pour le mérite et honnêtement c'était
une pure onas triompher et au palais d
été
l'âme toute l'équipe est extraordinaire
aimé jacquet avait les jeunes soient
dont j'étais convaincu et maintenant que
nathalie tauziat passe la même chose
demain
partons maintenant à rome c'est bien
compréhensible à bas la déception des
supporteurs italiens le match a été
suivi avec une immense ferveur devant
des écrans géants alain de chalvron
voici le penalty manqué de bibia dur la
fin du suspense la fin des espérances
la fin du mondial pour les italiens la
tristesse et le désespoir
je suis si triste je n'ai pas de mots
dit cette dame
vive l'italie mes compliments à la
france de celui ci 3 mondial
trois faits aux penaltys qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire se désespère celui là
pourtant sur cette petite place de rome
on a vécu le match comme au stade de
france voici une occasion italienne
manqué un coup franc français
l'angoissé et le soulagement oui on a
tous vécu comme au stade de france avec
le même suspense est aussi la même
passion tout autre était l'ambiance au
palais farnèse l'ambassade de france où
l'on avait réuni quelques personnalités
journalistes pour la plupart ami de la
france autour d'un ambassadeur
passionnés ici on se laisse moins aller
mais on réagit tout de même commentaire
en fin de première mi temps
la france avait fait plus de jeu que
l'italie mais dans les contres
l'italie rétais dangereuses ont le
pouvoir là la poule à faire moi je pense
qu'on c'est l'italie qui va gagner parce
que la france et ses traversées et va
être complètement bout en deuxième mi
temps j'ai peur j'étais plus optimistes
au début là je suis un peu troublé si
l'italie gagne le drapeau italien
flottera à côté du drapeau français ce
soir sur le palais farnèse
c'est ce que j'ai décidé et bien
finalement le drapeau français et
restera seul au milieu des échafaudages
il nous retrouvons en direct de rome
alain de chalvron bien sûr l'inquiétude
des supporteurs on l'a vu et enfin la
déception oui la déception voyez ici on
est au stade de marbre à côté du stade
olympique et il était prévu une grande
fête et ben vous voyez derrière moi
c'est complètement vide la fête et
évidemment il n'y en aura pas oui les
italiens sont déçus vous savez à quel
point ce peuple et est passionné par le
football a que les espoirs qu'il avait
vis dans ce mondial et dans cette partie
en particulier donc c'est vrai ça nul à
lui une allure un peu de désespoir
national ce soir rome
enfin c'est pas non plus la fin du monde
alors il faut dire quand même que
pendant toute là toute la partie pendant
tout le match les commentaires des
journalistes italiens des commentateurs
en particulier ceux de la rai on était
vraiment très élogieux pour la france et
finalement je crois que l'italie ce soir
be que c'était finalement une victoire
assez mérité de l'équipe de france merci
alain de chalvron les départs pour les
vacances d'été aujourd'hui la journée
classée orange sur la route en ile de
france comme en province les premiers
bouchons fait leur apparition notamment
aux sorties de paris bison futé
conseille à tous ceux qui n'auraient pas
encore pris le volant de partir plus tôt
demain en fin de journée aujourd'hui
affluence record dans les gares pour
cette seule journée
la sncf attend 350 mille voyageurs bien
évidemment au départ des grandes gares
de lyon et montparnasse de nombreux
trains supplémentaires trafic en hausse
également dans les aéroports pour les
deux jours à venir
damien thévenot patrick fandio
la démarche assurée et le shaq bien
enfoncée voici la collection était 98 du
parfait vacancier
depuis cet après midi et jusqu'à
dimanche soir un million de voyageurs
sans oublier leurs bagages vont
transiter par les gares parisiennes 1500
trains au total c'est 30 % de plus qu'un
week-end normal mais ce n'est pas tout
occupé de toute la partie technique
également des talents commerciaux
l'accueil ici les destinations les plus
prisées sont la côte d'azur ou l'italie
on part en vacances plutôt en famille
sans jamais oublier l'essentiel
et avec des projets plein la tête
plongeante départ à destination de dans
les aéroports même affluence 850 vols
aujourd'hui au départ d'orly c15
fonction de plus qu'en temps normal
sept cent mille vacanciers transiteront
par les deux aéroports parisiens d'ici à
dimanche soir
destination la mer et le ciel est cet
après midi et c'est plutôt inhabituel
plusieurs centaines de vacanciers aurait
presque regretter de devoir embarquer
scotché aux écrans géants ils n'ont pas
manqué une miette de la rencontre france
italie dans la région lyonnaise
maintenant point de passage obligé pour
de nombreux vacanciers tout a été fait
pour que les départs se déroule le plus
fluide mans possible à nouveau
dispositif vient d'être mise en place
il s'agit d' d'affichage sur différents
points d'autoroute indiquant à l'avance
les éventuels bouchons et le temps qu'il
faudra pour les franchir un système que
les parisiens connaissent bien sûr les
périphériques de la capitale
merci des fichiers tirer simonet il
fallait se contenter de ça
un bouchon de 3 km après vend désormais
sur l'autoroute a7 les panneaux à
messages variables eux ne parle plus
seulement de distance mais deux temps
des capteurs électroniques situés tous
les 5 km le long des voies alimente des
ordinateurs capables de convertir les
kilomètres en int où on a toutes les
données qui atterrissent sur sur un
système informatique
ensuite ces données sont exploitées par
un douzième officielle don qui est un
logiciel de calcul des temps de parcours
une fois vérifié ces calculs sont
transmis en quelques secondes aux écrans
géants de l'autoroute constamment
réactualisée pour les situations
classiques on arrive à une précision de
5 à 10% et on ne passe et fiable il ya
sans doute encore des situations un
petit peu plus extraordinaires sur
lequel on aura encore à pau
le dispositif repose sur un système de
comptage très pointue prenant même en
compte la longueur des véhicules de
l'information quasi en temps réel qui
fait mouche auprès des usagers
les gens vont souvent avec des rendez
vous donc si sable le temps qu'ils vont
passer dans vos chances et conditionne
avec les portables et tout ça et pour
prévenir qu'ils n'arrivent pas par
exemple
et demain c'est nouveau minuteur
pourrait bien être très utile aux 212
d'automobilistes attendu sur l'autoroute
du soleil serait donc très nombreux à
prendre la route aujourd'hui demain pour
rejoindre vos lieux de vacances les
habituels conseils de prudence bien
évidemment après les accidents à
répétition sur la route nationale 10
dans les landes où l'année dernière on
s'en souvient douze personnes avaient
trouvé la mort lors d'une collision
le ministère des transports a remis aux
normes cet axe de circulation et en
profite pour lancer une campagne de
sensibilisation
alban nicosie à la location c'est un
endroit marqué par le destin liposthey y
dans les landes au bord de la nationale
10 un petit chemin privé désormais
fermée ici il y à un peu plus d'un an un
autocar portugais percuté un camion qui
sortait du chemin l'accident a fait 12
morts douze victimes de plus serait on
tenté d'écrire
l'itinéraire est si dangereux que les
allemands l'ont surnommé l'autoroute de
la mort un an après des leçons ont été
tirées
jean marie aube à terre est chargé de la
modernisation de cet acte il ya en gros
une soixantaine d'accès privé de ce type
ou même le plus beaucoup plus étroit et
l'objectif c'est effectivement de les
supprimer un budget d'un milliard trois
cents millions a été débloquée une route
parallèle est désormais réservé au
transit local la signalisation a été
renforcée l'objectif est de rendre cette
nationale aussi sûr qu'une autoroute
reste à inciter les conducteurs à la
prudence
briser cette idée de fatalité on peut
réduire de moitié le nombre de tués à
wil chacun les choix routes de france
avec un chiffre qui ne baisse plus
depuis trois ans d'où l'idée de
promouvoir les initiatives locales de
prévention sur les aires de repos par
exemple sans oublier les traditionnels
consignes de vigilance donné aux
gendarmes en cette saison
en floride aux états unis de violents
incendies échappe à tout contrôle par
dizaines de milliers les habitants sont
évacuées et les flammes se situe
maintenant à moins de 100 kilomètres du
centre d'attractions de disneyworld pour
le gouverneur de l'état de floride c'est
le pire incendie qu'on ait jamais vu
gérard griesbeck cent mille hectares de
forêts partis en fumée le sud des états
unis brûlent depuis des semaines la
floride mais aussi le texas du jamais vu
depuis les années 30
des pompiers débordés face à l'ampleur
du sinistre
des centaines de maisons ont été
détruites des milliers de gens sont
partis sur les routes
la police a monté des barrages la
floride et le texas ont été déclarées
zones sinistrées
on parle de plusieurs milliards de
dollars de dégâts
et ce n'est pas fini avec de nouveaux
records de chaleur presque 40 degrés
pire c'est de ne pas savoir si la maison
qui brûle est la vôtre ou pas les
quelques orages qui se sont abattus
n'ont fait qu'aggraver la situation la
pluie n'est pas assez abondante pour
éteindre des flammes attisées par le
vent alors que la foudre allument de
nouveaux foyers
on craint maintenant que ces incendies
ne se répande vers la californie
l'arizona le nouveau mexique où le
nevada déjà touchés par la sécheresse
en italie maintenant des milliers
d'hectares de maquis méditerranéen ont
été détruits par des incendies plusieurs
milliers de pompiers dans différentes
régions du sud en sardaigne en sicile
tente de venir à bout du feu alimenté
par le vent le scirocco
bill clinton a quitté hong kong
aujourd'hui dernière étape de son voyage
en chine le président américain a dit
avoir le sentiment du devoir accompli
mais aux états unis des éditorialistes
fonta bilan plus mitigé de ce voyage le
premier depuis le massacre de la place
tiananmen il ya neuf ans à pékin comme à
washington on se dit bien décidé à jouer
le partenariat stratégique
l'une des phrases clés de ce voyage en
france
retour en france à trois mois des
élections en allemagne celui qui fait
figure de favori dans les sondages
gerhard schröder était à paris
aujourd'hui le social-démocrate
multiplie les contacts avec les
dirigeants français il a rencontré
lionel jospin pendant un peu plus d'une
heure jacques chirac lui n'a pu le
rencontrer puisqu'il était au stade de
france une rencontre préparée par sa
nouvelle conseillère une française
brigitte sauzay qui travaille notamment
à adoucir l'image un peu anti françaises
de gerhard schröder les serbie mais ils
ne parlent pas le français mais il n'a
pas de soucis d'interprète pour sa
première visite en france en qualité de
candidat à la chancellerie
le socialiste gerhard schröder cette
affiche est non pas avec sa femme mais
avec brigitte sauzay actuelle directrice
du service des interprètes du quai
d'orsay des raretés brigitte un
véritable couple franco-allemand tout
diplomatique celui là elle est toujours
à ses côtés
mais à distance évident photographes et
cameramen
car brigitte sauzay est embarrassé ce
matin la presse allemande
annoncé à grand renfort de titres et en
français s'il vous plaît
quel serait je cite le bras droit de
gerhard schröder s'il emportait les
élections le 27 septembre prochain
madame chose et est quelqu'un dont j'ai
appris à apprécier le travail
il m'arrivait de la croiser ici et là et
c'est quelqu'un qui m'aidera à mieux
comprendre les subtilités de la france
qui a un regard à la fois solidaire et
critique sur l'alsace
brigitte sauzay une jeune traductrice
devenu diplomate malgré elle à 23 ans
elle fait sa première chaise une
traduction simultanée dans le jargon des
traducteurs georges pompidou et willy
brandt
puis c'est valéry giscard d'estaing et
helmut schmidt kohl et mitterrand 40
sommet des milliers d'heures de
traduction elle est la mémoire vivante
d'un quart de siècle de relations
franco-allemandes observatrice engagée
elle a créé dans le brandebourg un
institut de coopération entre les deux
pays et de cette vie marquée par
l'histoire de la construction européenne
elle a tiré un livre au titre
prémonitoire retour à berlin
en irlande du nord nouvelle vague
d'incendiés d'origine criminelle cette
nuit ce sont des bâtiments protestants
et une école primaire catholique qui ont
été touchés à belfast climat de tension
alors que doit se tenir dimanche indice
il apporta donne ce défilés orangistes
annuel doit passer par le quartier
catholique et tony blair tente de
désamorcer cette crise en ayant
peut-être des entretiens avec les
dirigeants politiques disent aujourd'hui
le deuxième garde du corps de la
princesse diana était aujourd'hui
entendu comme témoin et à sa demande par
le juge d'instruction alexander winfield
n'était pas présent lors de l'accident
il devait s'exprimer sur l'organisation
de la sécurité de la princesse valérie
ermite une sortie discrète du palais de
justice
alexander winfield en cinq gardes du
corps de dodi al fayed vient juste de
démissionner de ses fonctions
c'est donc librement qu'il a pu parler
de la sécurité de la princesse diana une
sécurité qu'il aurait jugé insuffisante
depuis 1992 avec traoré jones il
protégeait dodi al fayed trébry jones
l'unique rescapée de l'accident vient
lui aussi récemment de démissionner
apparemment excédé par les pressions
qu'aurait exercées sur lui
mohamed al fayed l'entente ne semble
plus très cordiale entre les gardes du
corps et leur ancien employeur
l'avocat de trésorerie jones vient de
demander aux us que soit entendu les
dirigeants du rite afin de connaître
leurs éventuelles responsabilités dans
l'accident
ce juge a pas pour le moment
essentiellement instruit les faits
concernant les photographes pratiquement
pas sur d'autres points notamment la
question de la connaissance de
l'alcoolisme de ripoll
la question d'éventuels problèmes de
sécurité qui n'étaient pas respectées
autant de points qui demeurent vraiment
en suspens et qui mérite d'être
totalement clarifiée
un employé du ritz a déclaré que la
direction de l'hôtel aurait demandé de
mentir en déclarant qu henri paul le
chauffeur de la mercedes n'avait pas bu
ce soir là ce sont toutes ces questions
des treilles jones voudrais éclaircir le
conseil d'état annulé aujourd'hui la
convention des médecins généralistes
signé en mars 97 pas d'incidence sur le
remboursement des assurés sociaux
cette convention régit les relations
entre les généralistes et la cnam
jacques chirac a signé la loi sur la
chasse aux oiseaux migrateurs cette loi
adoptée à la grande majorité par
l'assemblée il ya quelques jours
s'opposent la réglementation européenne
enfin à marseille sachez que trois
personnes ont été mises en examen et
écroué pour corruption de fonctionnaires
de police là des hommes écroués et fiché
au grand banditisme et son nom avait été
cité dans la sphère de l'assassinât du
juge michel retour au mondial
inutile de préciser que les spectateurs
qui avaient la chance d'assister en
direct au stade de france à ce match
pour la demi finale ont laissé éclater
leur joie dès la fin de la rencontre
philippe visseyrias dominique bonnet c
pour les nerfs n'ont surtout pas ce que
noah que paraguay ce n'était pas évident
mais alors là le traduire je suis
vraiment content suivez chez vidé
métro porte enfin arrivée aux penaltys
vous a dit on a perdu
j'ai pas regardé les gitanes de 10h sur
gagné deux fois contre la prolongation
nous on est mort blizzard est un dealer
record de 1006 niles aussi plein pot
guillaume samica 90 minutes jamais on
veut les allemands à 0 en demi finale
voilà ce qu'on veut à la 90e minute sur
un penalty qui n'existe pas voilà seront
dans la capitale mais aussi un peu
partout en france la vie s'est arrêtée
c'est ce qu'ont dû aux performances des
joueurs l'exemple de ce camping antibes
où les vacanciers s'étaient organisés
pour ne manquer aucun prix le match
thibault de barbeyrac claude sicard cela
fait dix ans que giuseppe et ornella
passent leurs vacances au camping sur la
côte d'azur disant qu'ils viennent avec
leur téléviseur portable
mais aujourd'hui signe du destin
l'antenne a cassé impossible de capter
la rai
dans l'urgence il faut fermer la
caravane est parti à voir le match
au bar du camping pas franchement
l'idéal ici on voit pas grand chose mais
surtout on n'entend rien dans la
caravane on avait un bon son mais là
vraiment pas et viennent de turin leurs
petites amies son parti à la plage
pendant qu'ils regardent le match entre
hommes des machos pas très rassurée je
pense que la france est la mieux partie
ou et d'italie est aussi une bonne
équipe
de toute façon le match sera long très
longue
plutôt bon pronostiqueur les italiens
mais comme tout le camping réunis au bar
pas très expansif pendant le match
trop de tension puis vient
l'insoutenable séance des tirs au but
une fois l'italie une fois la fin 19h15
après presque trois heures
san antonio malédiction divine hausse et
l'italie étaient des mêmes valeurs mais
c'est dieu qui a décidé
une après midi de chien pour eux mais
les vacances sont encore longue
ils auront sûrement d'autres occasions
de garder des bons souvenirs de la
france la plupart des entreprises était
confronté cet après midi à l'intérêt de
leurs employés pour le match france
italie certaines sociétés ont pris le
parti de la transparence en autorisant
une pause télé organisées à l'intérieur
même de l'entreprise
l'exemple à montpellier de cette société
d'informatique karine comazzi et
dominique pradalié fin de semaine
studieuse pour les informaticiens de
dell computer chacun se concentre sur
son travail
mais soudain le bug en clair il est 16
heures 20 et ce sont des calculs d'un
autre type qui occupe les esprits
moi je verrais plutôt la france gagne et
on va dire un but à zéro à peu près son
classique 2 0 il dit moi je dis plutôt 1
020 matinée pour l'italie allez la
france 16h30 la salle de réunion
résonnent des cris de la petite centaine
d'employés venus soutenir les bleus à
moins que les bleus ce ne soit les
italiens difficile de s'y retrouver en
fin de semaine quand ils jouent les
bleus en blanc bien super bien c'est
vraiment déçu paire d'attaquants ils
sont ils sont vraiment superbes horizon
un peu du mal et barcella et le travail
ça se passe comme ça mais c'est bon se
lancent un programme n'y a pas de
problème
et mais on va gagner et on attend les
appels des clients mais on répondra
juste après le match alors de terminer
je pensais que c'était une bonne idée
pour rassembler tout le monde et que
tout le monde regarde le match en groupe
plutôt que chacun parte en avant
possible fin du temps réglementaire l'
angoisse grimpe d'un cran les
prolongations ces tirs
leur but et des tirs au but est arrivé
et puis nous retrouvons sur les
champs-elysées françois brabant la foule
des supporteurs prêts j'imagine à faire
la fête une partie de la nuit là-bas ça
continue ça continue regardez c'est une
véritable marée humaine qui déferle sur
les sur les champs elysées y sont venus
à pied alors que d'ordinaire on
s'attendait plutôt à un défilé de et un
concours de klaxons et bien là ils sont
venus à pied ils sont venus à pied parce
qu'on on en met plus des supporters
comme ça sur les champs-elysées et là
ils sont très nombreux et ils vont faire
la fête jusqu'au bout de la nuit
parce qu'une victoire comme ça ça
s'arrose merci françois brabant tout
autre sujet la pietà le chef-d'oeuvre
inachevé de michel-ange est aussi sa
sculpture la plus mystérieuse
michel-ange voulu la détruire
pour quelles raisons les historiens
attendent beaucoup des scientifiques
pour répondre à cette question
explication jean-claude allanic
florence tels que michel-ange pouvait
déjà la contempler il y a plus de 400
ans au musée du duo mots l'une des
oeuvres les plus mystérieuses du
sculpteur de la renaissance la pietà
florentine la vierge et marie-madeleine
reconnu en le corps du christ sous le
regard de nycomed à 70 ans
michel-ange voulait en faire son
chef-d'oeuvre ultime celui qui devait
orner sa tombe
mais dix ans plus tard l'artiste dans
n'était pas venu à pau par dépit il
s'acharnera à coups de masse sur la
sculpture la brisent en plusieurs
morceaux
la pietà ne sera resterait qu'après sa
mort sans qu'on comprenne vraiment son
geste destructeur
un mystère qui sera sans doute bientôt
élucidé grâce à l'informatique
une mise au service de l'art avant le
réveil wright de haut une des choses que
nous aimerions faire c'est enlever tout
est partie réparée ce qui naturellement
impossible dans la réalité et voir ce
que michel-ange à vue après avoir brisé
c'est ce qu'on tue ça devrait donner une
bonne idée de ce qui le traquaient
faisait par rapport à ce qu'il tente
elle accomplit entièrement numérisée et
reconstituer en trois dimensions par les
ordinateurs la pietà florentine va
pouvoir désormais être étudié par les
historiens de l'art dans tous ses
détails
grâce aux images virtuelles on pourra
même visualiser les parties manquantes
comme la jambe gauche du christ détruite
par michel-ange et jamais retrouvé en
bien mais nécessaire bien sûr on avait
des documents qui donnait des détails
sur la position de l'agent mais là on va
pouvoir comprendre vraiment comment elle
était placée et où elle est et poseur et
réaliser une reconstitution très précise
et très proche de la réalité
verdict des ordinateurs dans six mois on
sera alors quatre siècles plus tard
pourquoi michel-ange avaient rogné la
pietà
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres la
victoire de l'équipe de france est la
toute dernière seconde aux tirs au but
un match d'une qualité exceptionnelle
pour les tricolores qui ont démontré
qu'ils étaient capables d'aller en demi
finale peut-être même en finale mais
départs pour les vacances d'été je re
orange sur les routes d'avant un samedi
classé rouge dans les gares 350 mille
voyageurs attendus aujourd'hui un trafic
aérien beaucoup plus dense tout de suite
le point route avec valérie maurice
suivi du football avec eux le quart de
finale brésil danemark sur france 2 dans
quelques instants en direct du stade de
la beaujoire à nantes
je vous remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
oui